[Music]
picture the shyest female friend
relative or loved one you know
a real
introvert she can't stand parties and
playing the dating game is her idea of a
living hell you won't catch her dead in
a bar but imagine someday everything
changes she's suddenly more relaxed more
outgoing she goes out to parties and now
you keep seeing her with this one guy
again and again and again it seems like
these days
all she does is spend time with this guy
and to think he's never even introduced
himself to you he's practically a total
stranger but your friend seems happy
enough so it doesn't bother you until
one day something strange happens
your friend just starts
screaming you can't explain it she can't
explain it her doctor can't explain it
nobody can explain it all you know is
that for months on end she has
involuntary screaming fits like
something out of a nightmare but still
she always smiles she seems happy as
long as you don't look at her eyes
there's something oddly glassy about
them they seem plastic dead
your friend is experiencing a dangerous
phenomenon known to the scp foundation
as
scp-3512 an anomaly that only seems to
affect women between the ages of 18 and
40. one woman is already dead as a
result of this and an additional nine
others affected by this strange anomaly
have been catalogued and contained in
standard humanoid containment chambers
for study at first the foundation
couldn't draw any logical conclusions
for why these women were spontaneously
experiencing total personality changes
and pronounced screaming fits all the
foundation had to go on was that the
first cluster of infected individuals
originated in barcelona spain a
foundation facility in boston dispatched
one of their best field operatives agent
riley cooper on an investigative mission
to barcelona they wanted her to get to
the bottom of this phenomenon and put a
stop to it before things went any
further while in spain agent cooper
would be assisted by a local foundation
operative agent tomas rey whose intimate
knowledge of the locale would provide a
key advantage in the investigation
together they'd crack this thing and
make sure no other women were harmed at
least that's what the foundation had
hoped instead both agents disappeared
under horrific circumstances
during the investigation and today we're
going to tell you about the final days
of agent cooper and agent rey and why
attempting to investigate scp-3512
was the last thing they ever did agent
cooper arrived on the 15th of july 2016
and stepped out into the scorching
summer heat of spain agent cooper was
everything you'd want in a field
operative for the foundation intelligent
dedicated and professional she
rendezvoused with agent ray who was a
comparatively smooth and laid-back
figure the two of them began their
investigation by speaking to the friends
and families of some of the infected
women pretending to be doctors working
for the world health organization agent
cooper in her personal diaries noted how
creepy and unreal the affected woman
seemed most of the interviews were
unnerving and sad but not exactly
enlightening however as things drew to a
close a younger sister of one of the
victims mentioned a single word blackout
even the mention of the word caused the
victim to descend into another screaming
fit agent rey's local knowledge came in
handy once again he recognized the name
it was a popular local nightclub agent
cooper and agent ray knew they had to
investigate the club and went undercover
as regular patrons for the first several
hours they were there nothing happened
but then at 2 am a man approached agent
cooper at the bar he was a tall blonde
man with an unsettling intensity to him
he asked without a hint of irony what
agent cooper's favorite star was there
was something off about this man his
word choice was too precise almost
rehearsed he wasn't drunk in the
slightest agent cooper intuited that
this was the kind of guy who liked to
take advantage of women in bars when she
threw a glance at agent rey signaling
him that something was off the stranger
quickly left for agent cooper this only
further confirmed her suspicions the
agents paid off the bouncer to find out
if the tall stranger was a regular and
then what his name was after being
slipped some cash the bouncer was all
too eager to share this strange man came
here all the time and he knew his name
too it was joseph oriol agent cooper and
agent ray wasted no time in finding
joseph orrio's apartment and receiving
authorization to perform a comprehensive
search on the premises and as soon as
they did they found cause to declare the
man a person of interest in the
scp-3512 investigation the apartment was
a smorgasbord of suspicious activity
oriole was a software developer but he
had extensive records on the
architecture of the local area including
buildings utilities and railway tunnels
joseph correctly figured the
investigators were coming for him and
had fled his home before they could get
there and this was only the tip of the
iceberg agent cooper and ray then found
a book with a plain cover sitting on
ordials kitchen table cooper thought it
was a publisher's proof a kind of
pre-publication prototype copy of a book
they collected it but didn't read it
straight away worrying about its
potentially cognito-hazardous nature and
besides they were a little distracted by
the homemade monstrosity sitting next to
it it looked to agent cooper like a
sculpted blob of wax with a series of 12
makeshift legs made from a variety of
substances including lego pieces rose
stems a crab claw and a corkscrew rae
called cooper into the bathroom where
there were a number of boxes filled with
similar supplies bodkins quills doll's
limbs wire and syringes when cooper led
rey back into the kitchen to see
oriole's little art project later
classified by the foundation as
scp-3512-1
they were surprised and unnerved to see
that it was already gone everything
about this situation screamed anomalous
and it only got worse later that night
when cooper actually read the book she
collected from orioles apartment being
sure to wear cognitohazard filtering
goggles as a precaution the book now
known to the scp foundation as
scp-3512-2
was entitled the more you know a pickup
artist's bible and was written by a man
using the pen name enigma as the title
suggests it was a misogynistic 625-page
non-fiction book on the subject of
picking up women it even had a forward
on its effectiveness by popular american
rapper calvin broughtos jr better known
as snoop dogg
though after being contacted by the
foundation mr dog claimed no knowledge
of the book the book began with your
typical creepy and dehumanizing
seduction tactics for the first 11
chapters but the following 12 chapters
which were each titled chapter 12 delved
into increasingly creepy and esoteric
techniques including advanced geometric
proofs the interpretation of dreams
do-it-yourself surgical techniques
symbolism and architecture and anomalous
rituals the books afterward is composed
of more than fifteen thousand anagrams
of the book's title laid out in spiral
and triangular patterns cooper took a
particular morbid interest in chapter 18
where it appeared to provide
instructions on creating objects that
look like the anomalous
scp-3512-1 sculptures found in orioles
apartment the chapter read make a rough
ball of the materials you've harvested
and place it in the freezer for 6 to 12
hours pork fat can be used but will have
less satisfactory results who knew right
while you wait you can prepare the limbs
concentrate on articulation rather than
strength you may want to add simple
tools to some limbs if the object of
your desire is more careful than most
but remember that the more complicated
you make them the more precise your
sculpting will need to be
lay your prepared limbs out on a clean
flat surface once your adipose
preparation has had time to freeze
carefully carve it into the shape you
learned in chapter 12. you will know it
is ready when you see it start smiling
at you now introduce the limbs they
should take almost immediately wait
until your intended is likely to be
sleeping then concentrate your thoughts
on her face and particularly the inside
of her mouth and throat soon you'll see
your new friends scurry off ready to
help you establish social dominance if
this wasn't disturbing enough the next
chapter advised the use of scissors and
the removal of the aspiring
seductionist's pinky finger as well as
the pinky fingers of their family
members to help increase their seductive
power it appeared to cooper that these
rituals and seemingly living anomalous
sculptures were behind the
scp-3512 phenomena and that night they
got their next break in the case the two
agents had sent the architectural plans
found in orioles apartment back to
foundation hq and while most of it was
found to be public records of the local
area there was one notable abnormality a
secret exit in a little used subway
tunnel that led to a grand spiral
staircase heading down to
well they just didn't know and it was
the job of agents cooper and rey to find
out they set out later that night on
what they didn't know would be the last
mission they'd ever take the two agents
descended the spiral staircase for what
felt like hours until they reached an
elaborate system of tunnels at the
bottom they began exploring the tunnels
and found that they were cramped and
covered in strange ritualistic carvings
occasionally they even saw clusters of
human pinky fingers sticking out of the
wall they kept going and soon found that
whatever they were moving towards was
loud immensely hot and the smell was
truly horrific as the almost deafening
mechanical drone got louder and louder
and the smell grew worse they knew they
must be getting closer to whatever was
happening here the tunnels soon to open
up to a giant chamber where they found
something truly horrific in front of
them was what looked to be an entire
river of bubbling liquid human fat the
exact kind that the author enigma had
recommended using to create the
mind-altering
scp-3512-1 sculptures in his book and
speaking of the book across the river
agent cooper and agent ray noticed a
complex series of printing presses
presumably churning out more copies of
the more you know a pickup artist bible
to spread its anomalous influence far
and wide however before the duo could
literally stop the presses they were
attacked a huge 3512-1 entity with legs
made out of human spines jumped down
from the ceiling it latched on to agent
cooper embedding her in its waxy body
and dragging her into the disgusting
river of hot fat agent ray was separated
and lost in the tunnels presumed dead as
he hasn't been seen since agent cooper
however would live to see a far more
horrifying fate she was carried down
river by the greasy tide until her body
was washed up in a different chamber
that looked to be a place of worship
below the sagrada familia basilica
filled with thousands of tiny crawling
3512-1s
there she met the creator of all of this
a horrific thing that was perhaps once a
man now covered in wriggling living
pinky fingers sticking out of its body
it was disgusting but she wouldn't mind
for long in fact the next time cooper
woke up she didn't have a problem with
it at all she was changed just like all
the others another victim of the
scp-3512 phenomenon she was giggly
outgoing and uninhibited all despite the
nightmarish situation she was in she
loved the horrifying monster that had
done this to her she didn't have a
choice not to and when he was tired of
her he took her and threw her down into
a large pit in this chamber the same one
where the many dead bodies of his
previous mind-controlled girlfriends
were laying neither agent was ever seen
after this mobile task force zeta9 aka
molerats have been sent into the tunnels
to investigate but they didn't find any
of the locations comparable to the ones
seen by cooper and rey in their last
hours whoever did all of this is still
out there still dangerous so ladies if
you ever see a guy you know reading a
copy of the more you know a pickup
artist's bible run like your life and
sanity depends on it because this time
it really really does
now check out
scp-001 the children are boris cycle and
scp-4999 someone to watch over us tale
for more records of mysterious phenomena
from the scp foundation